[Music]
mon of us fans know that gadora the
three-headed dragon also known to
Monarch as Monster Zero was trapped
within the ice sheets of Antarctica for
a very long time only to be reawakened
from its dant state by Alan Jonah and
Emma Russell in kotm but how it was
sealed there is still a big mystery a
big blood hole and speculations are up
and running again and with the
monsterverse now constant soft reboots
of story lines this is left open to
debate once more now the big question is
which Titan froze gar in Antarctica
there are quite a few possible scenarios
as to how the golden alien Titan found
itself in the world's biggest popsicle
and now let's get to each one of these
so firstly let's list down the two
criteria that are needed to put Monster
Zero there firstly the Titan in question
has to be stronger than it to be able to
at least put him in a state of
unconsciousness before he freezes him
otherwise he would just wriggle away as
the icing is in progress secondly the
Titan has to have freezing of frost
abilities there are quite a few ones out
there that have these as of the current
low now the director of kotm Michael doy
stated that Godzilla had already beaten
gidora in the past and that theirs was
an ancient rivalry of two Apex Titans at
a class above all others but since the
monsterverse is currently evolving with
a more expansive of low we might just
get a slight change in the history of
this event now since Godzilla actually
had quite a struggle against gdor in
kotm and was only able to win with the
help of Mothra it is highly unlikely
that the Gman had the physical strength
in his prek kotm form actually pre 20104
form to be able to at least best Gora in
melee battle the Monarch series also
showed that Godzilla was actually around
300 ft or 90 m in 1954 100 ft lesser
than his kotm version and therefore
would have been around 221 ft shorter
than Monster Zero this means that in his
ancient juvenile size he would not have
been able to defeat a way bigger and
more powerful gadora this would only be
possible only if his enemy was also
smaller and weaker back in the day so
even if Godzilla was lucky in defeating
his rival back then that still leaves
the second criteria null which is how
will Godzilla freeze gdor in eyes when
Godzilla plainly has EXT extremely hot
powers like the atomic breath and a
nuclear pulse so now let's go by with
the second criteria first and then work
our way back to the first one let's take
a look at the Titans that have Frost
powers or the freezing abilities as of
now we have currently three Titans that
fit this description the first one is
Siller with her liquid nitrogen
secretion abilities which has been said
to have started lowering down the
oceanic temperatures to stable levels
the second one is the frost varic from
Mod Arch the legacy of monsters which
can inhale quite a lot of air and in
turn lower down the temperature in the
surroundings to minus levels this Titan
in fact feeds on fire and heat which
lowers the energy levels to minimal
levels in the vicinity the only problem
with these two is their physical
strength though which is quite low on
the Titan scale then lastly we have the
third Titan with frost powers and this
is none other than shimu a new Titan
that will appear in Godzilla Kong the
new Empire in a few months time he has a
power called the frostbite breath now
from these three Titans only one of them
can check out the first criteria as well
you know the physical strength one Silla
is a beta Titan and will not be able to
overpower gidora at all in order to
freeze him over in the Antarctic eyes
the frost varic 2 is too small to affect
anything of the magnitude of Monster
Zero which only leaves shimu as the sole
Titan that can possibly overpower Gora
and Ice him as well shimo Ste to
actually be the first ever Titan and the
oldest amongst all the Undiscovered
threat that can defeat any other single
Titan in combat and maybe will freeze
Godzilla in the first half of the movie
gxk and then Godzilla will evolve and
come back for a second round but there
are also other scenarios that would lead
to the same outcome and it doesn't have
to require a specific single Titan to
check both criteria monster Zera could
have been defeated by Godzilla and his
incapacitated body thrown over or could
have fallen down to an icy hole only to
freeze due to the extreme cold weather
in Antarctica he could have also been
defeated by Godzilla in a battle in the
coast of Antarctica much like the
encounter outside of the coast of Mexico
in kotm mind you that back then the sea
levels must have been higher and then
the decapitated body of gidora would
slowly start to heal but then the eyes
would form in the Ice Age and would slow
down the healing or the regenerative
processes and hence him being dorin in
in a hole in the ice over there come to
think about it that hole was at an
elevation that is actually below the sea
level so this scenario has a very high
Mark now the last one the last scenario
here is that gidora must have been
defeated by numerous other Titans that
answered the call of the alpha and team
up with Godzilla in a fight against the
three-headed dragon the alien Invader
this would have been like the invasion
of the astromonster from the showa era
or from the Destroy All Monsters story
line where two or three other kaijus
would have been able to overpower the
larger golden bees so in the monster
verse These Titans that awakened a kotm
like Sila Behemoth methusa the others
before they went into hibernation must
have Allied themselves with the alpha
back then which is Godzilla and together
overpowered the larger extraterrestrial
threat and when gdor was absolutely
beaten to a pulp he would have been
frozen over by Silla liquid nitrogen
Powers but in the the end all of these
theories would be subject to legendar
changes of the lore and these theories
are all still void and open to debate
which is why we have the comment section
down below for fans to you know put your
thoughts into now if you like this video
then watch this other one as well and do
check out our channel for more moners
content we might just have things that
you haven't seen before like subscribe
and we'll see you in the next video take
care
fam